all eyes were on paris's constitutional
Council where the decision would be made
for police spotters the view from the
roof waiting to see how France would
react
yet in the clothes shop next door we
found Allah who believes these
incendiary days could have been avoided
I can understand people but don't accept
it but maybe it's necessary but it's the
government to explain why with correctly
France's president Emmanuel macron had
begun the day on a jovial visit to see
reconstruction work after the 2019 fire
at Notre Dame Cathedral
for him the day would also end in Smiles
with validation of his reforms he
insists France can't afford to keep the
pension age at 62 and it must be raised
to 64.
across Paris outside the town hall
workers from the left-wing cgt Union
gathered bitterly disappointed but
vowing to fight on president macron's
legal crisis may have ended but his
political crisis has not there are still
a lot of angry people in France who
refuse to accept his pension reforms
demonstrators have taken to the streets
every week since mid-January strikes
have hit France hard Stefan valdon works
on the railways as a ticket inspector
taking industrial action means he hasn't
been paid I'm very disappointed I'm very
angry because we're on strike for four
weeks it's very difficult for us there's
a sense from some they may need new
tactics I don't know how long
someone can just talk talk
and with no reaction
for the old tactics of a hardcore
prepared to take on the riot police saw
skirmishes inside streets in Paris
France comes out of the pension ruling
fragmented over the question of how long
people should have to work Lisa Holland
Sky News Paris